paulo espino on the mound
for the washington nationals he makes
his a nationals debut he spent last year
at triple a for washington 10th round
selection
and he made it to the big leagues in
2017.
that one's lined to left field that's a
base hit for mccutchen so he's a board
and the phillies have the lead off
hitter aboard mccutcheon came into the
ball game hitting 241
he finished game one
with a hit in three at-bats
and there you see the four seams and
center cut
and that is well hit to left
stevenson chasing it setting up but he
makes a leaping catch
ball slicing right back over the top of
his ball cap
two down bryce thought he had a home run
he watched that andrew stevenson read it
perfectly off the bat and they'll face
uh david hale
second straight start for david hall
pitts good
first one
one ball and no strikes to stevenson
over to the right side kingry has it
easy play one out
trey turner is the hitter
and turner hits it the opposite way
that'll be in for a base hit it's going
to the wall that'll be his 14th double
of the year
the man just keeps on hitting
trey turner three for eight in this
series now
and that's his 29th extra base hit and
better going the other way this year in
baseball than trey turner it's not just
bloopers to write i mean with authority
now andrew nat switch it and catcher
it's one and two to nap with a runner at
second base
and andrew lines one into center field
of base hit gregorius around third
heading for home he'll score it's an rbi
single and the phillies strike first
here in the second inning 12 rbis for
injured knapp situation right there stay
up the middle don't try to pull it don't
try to do too much with it and roll over
hands inside nice right there two out
now and nap at second of the batter will
be roman quinn batting ninth in the
order
and he lines that one back through the
middle of base hit rounding third and
being waved home as andrew knapp the
throw to the plate on one hop he is safe
at home he got his hand in
it's an rbi single for roman quinn it's
a two-nothing phillies lead gets a first
pitch fastball from espino
hits a bullet up the middle and man that
is close
it looks like he got in there what a
good throw by michael a good tag good
slide everybody did everything right
nice swing
andrew stevenson ground ball to second
first time up
stevenson bases it to left taylor
running hardship hale sends him michael
a screaming home
and the gnats have cut the deficit in
half as andrew stevenson continues to
swing the bat beautifully play me or
trade me
andrew stevenson taking advantage or i
wouldn't say take an advantage he's
making his own playing time yeah well
here's jojo romero romero makes an
unbelievable entrance from the bullpen
and crush the red bull can on his leg
two on one out tying runs at second
soto
left field well hit
see
you
later first home run of september it
drives in three
and the nats lead four to two
and they hit the rebel kid maybe i mean
it was close
juan soto ladies and gentlemen four to
two nets and now we dance literally
right where he crushed the red bull on
his leg you can't make this up there's
the second baseman kingery curveball
swung on line deep to left going back on
it stevenson looking up and it is gone
about five rows up straight away left
field scott kingery with his third home
run of the season gets a hanging
breaking ball and he belts it
and the phillies are back to within a
run it's four to three scotty took a
couple of them for strikes and then he
said you know what throw it again and he
did he hung it and now the philly's
bullpen is stirring as you get down to
the left-handed hitting yada yall
hernandez good swing
tailing left field corner fair ball will
keep our eye on eric thames that ball
gets deep on mccutchen thames will score
easily
and the gnats grab one of those runs
right back it's five to three andrew
stevenson again
turns on it right field corner another
extra base hit another rbi
drew stevenson's thinking about three
here bryce harper slow coming up with
the ball
and then he throws a one way off line
philly's outfield defense has just been
shoddy to say the least nationals lead
six to three top of the fifth two on two
outs and the man to face him is dd
gregorius
there you go out to right center field
on the run of soto he's not going to get
it it's a one hop off the wall mccutchen
will score here comes baum he's heading
home it'll be a two-run double for
gregorius now it's a one-run game
national six phillies five
nowhere to put anybody now as the bases
are loaded finnegan trying to get out of
this sixth inning jam for the nats
up the middle ball scoots by the mound
tough play turner yes
the call is out their first base coach
paco figueroa waving at the dugout
phillies will challenge the call of joe
west joe west's call gets overruled it
is a 6-6 game roman quinn starts it off
phil gosling the ghost runner at second
hudson to the belt the pitch and quinn
pushes the bunt to third perfectly done
holt throws high throws it away and the
ball goes out of play
so on one pitch it's a run a throwing
error by holt gosselin scores quinn to
second and it's 7-6 philadelphia there's
yada yall hernandez
workman sets and fires
swinging a high drive right field deep
harper going back to the morning track
to the wall it's gone
yadiel hernandez wins it
you just can't make this stuff up